the newly passed covid relief package in  congress  may be in jeopardy last night president  trump released a video and suggested he  may not sign the 900 billion dollar  package  the money approved by lawmakers would  provide unemployment benefits and  stimulus checks to struggling americans  but the president says it doesn't do  enough i'm asking congress to amend this  bill and increase  the ridiculously low six hundred dollars  to two thousand dollars or four thousand  dollars  for a couple in a letter today you see  there house speaker nancy pelosi says  she wants to bring a standalone bill  along to increase the payments  however it requires republican  leadership to agree  the measure already approved by congress  has a veto proof majority